well the Special Counsel investigation
headed by Robert Muller was created you
will remember to investigate Russian
meddling in the 2016 election didn't
take much time to deduce there was very
little to investigate there but the
investigation didn't go away they never
do it broadened over and over until it
became what it is now which is a team of
Democratic attorneys prying into the
personal lives of anyone associated with
Donald Trump and sending some of them to
prison so what justifies the continued
existence of this investigation which is
a big question a few ass Kings frassle
The Wall Street Journal does though and
she joins us tonight
so Kim what is the pretext for
continuing this at this stage well it's
hard to know again we were supposed to
talk about Trump Russia collusion so far
in all of the time that the Special
Counsel has gone along he's not find any
evidence of that now his mandate did say
any related crimes so I guess if you
were going to give him a rationale you
could say if you found evidence of
wrongdoing he has an obligation to
follow those leads as well but I think
one of the frustrations out there among
a lot of people who are watching this is
that you now have this very one-sided
probe where all the people who were
accused of things and we're not
necessarily found guilty of any of those
accusations are still under the
spotlight whereas those who made the
accusations and potentially have done
some criminal activity of their own are
getting no scrutiny whatsoever so look
I'm not defending Michael Cohen who I
just want to say for the record I've
always thought was ridiculous sleaze
ball but if at the end we find out that
he didn't pay taxes on the sale of a
handbag and like brokered a deal to a
pornstar
I mean that's not really worth ending
the business of government for two years
is it is anyone going to admit that no
because they're so invested in this
point in legitimizing a rational look
ask yourself this question which is
somewhat mystifying Michael Cohen has
been brought up on two felony charges of
breaking campaign finance laws I've
written about campaign finance laws a
lot it is exceptionally rare that they
are ever prosecuted at a criminal level
they are almost always civil charges
why did they do it they did it so that
they could have a connection with Trump
and all the headlines that we've had
this week it's the only thing that I can
think of for why they would have gone
down that path especially because we
read that they had close to 20 charges
that they wanted to bring a game and
they dropped a number of them just so
that they could get the few that they
got on taxes and banks and and the
campaign finance violations but I mean
how does stabilizing is this for the
country I mean if you find out the
president's colluding with Vladimir
Putin you know bust him for it but if
people come away thinking this is up on
both sides but every everybody watching
knows what this is it's a bunch of
people who hate Trump we're trying to
bring him down by any means necessary
but when the smoke clears
does anyone trust the justice system at
all anymore well no and here's one of
the problems is look I think a lot of
Americans when Bob Muller was first up a
put in place thought all right get to
the bottom of this very serious
accusation was there Trump Russia
collusion Jack that that was a big deal
we deserved an answer to that but if
you're now gonna go down the line of
prosecuting all these other things and
then you're not even going to take a
look at the people who may have done
wrong in making these accusations and
Lodging that very serious accusation at
the top echelon of our government where
it was acted upon by the FBI I mean look
if you're gonna go after Michael Cohen
for campaign finance violations why is
nobody taking a look at the Hillary
Clinton campaign or the DNC who hired an
opposition research firm but did not
state that accurately on their comp
campaign finance forms they ran it
through a law firm and called it legal
services it just makes everybody so
cynical it just degrades
the country in a way that's gonna be
hard to recover from it's very sad to
watch you are one of the clearest
explainers of what's going on
Kim stressful and we appreciate that
thank you